Steve Bannon has accused Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell of being swamp monsters
my dear friend of the first female
physician ever elected to Congress
dr. nanhee worth will join the will join
our show to discuss the swamp
congressional gridlock in the wealth of
nations then Emily Butler and Jacob
berry will join the panel of deplorable
'z to talk about the biggest mistake in
modern political history Pope Francis's
implied admonition that pro-lifers must
support daca and Miss America's opinion
on Russian collusion I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
and before we do any of that we have a
sponsor marshal we got a sponsor some we
finally did it this is great we're gonna
possibly be able to keep the lights on
on more than just selling left us tears
tumblers so this and I'm real this was
Providence this was the perfect first
sponsor for our show we talk all the
time on the show about how nobody knows
anything about history that's why all
the hysterical people on the left are
talking about to Hitler or the Third
Reich or fall of Rome it's because no
one ever knows anything about history
other than the fall of Rome and the
Third Reich well luckily there is a
great new podcast I really like this
podcast I've listened to it so far
you've got to go check out the first
episode it's called tides of history
it's a new podcast from wonder II and
the podcast is from PhD historian
Patrick Wyman who happens also to be an
MMA analyst and he answers all of the
these two periods that constructed our
modern world antiquity so the classical
era the fall of Rome and the beginning
of modernity 1350 to 1650 the period
where we see the West building on all
that we have from classical antiquity
and creating the modern world creating
nation-states where does capitalism come
from why did all of these governments
organize in roughly the same way around
roughly the same period what why do we
have States to begin with how did modern
trade routes get started how did
globalization start what periods of
globalization have already happened
we're seeing a new period happening now
but when have they happened before and
why and what happens when you privatize
militaries sounds spooky you'll have to
listen to find out all of these
questions can be traced back to the
period of time during the Renaissance
and just before the Enlightenment so
what Patrick does it's so good
he takes what could be really dry
history I remember I was a history major
and you always hear that history is just
one fact after another
he takes what could be really dry boring
history and he weaves it into really
engaging narratives I listened to it
when I'm driving and it's a great way
it's really hard to take the time to
read
you know I only get an hour to to read a
day but I Drive a lot I'm in Los Angeles
if you commute you can listen to it and
it's just like injecting your brain with
history knowledge and so not only can
you impress people at cocktail parties
but you'll also be able to understand
your own civilization your own moment in
politics it will make you realize that
perhaps not everything is falling apart
or if it is all falling apart why is it
and where are the historical backgrounds
for that so what you should do is you
got a Google it right now tides of
history go and google it it's on Apple
podcasts and Google Play it's on
stitcher all those all of the podcasts
sites so look it up right now
tides of history it's with Patrick Wyman
I think you're really gonna like it and
tweet me and let me know what you think
about it because I've really enjoyed
listening to it so far and go over there
so we can keep these lights on come on
guys okay we had some explosive
political news over the weekend and that
was Steve bannon's interview with
Charlie Rose on 60 minutes if you missed
it for some reason if you were hiding
under a rock here is just a clip of it
to get the gist of it the Republican
establishment is trying to nullify the
2016 election that's a brutal fact we
have to face the Republican
establishment and establishment wants to
nullify the 2016 trying to nullify the
2016 election absolutely who I think I
think Mitch McConnell on tour the great
Paul Ryan they do not want Donald
Trump's populist economic nationalist
agenda to be implemented it's very
obvious it's obvious it's obvious it's
obvious as night follows day give me a
story that illustrates that well Mitch
McConnell we first met him I mean he was
he was he said I think in one of the
first meetings in Trump Tower with the
president as we're wrapping up he buddy
says I don't want to hear any more of
this drain the swamp talk they do not
support the president's program it's an
open secret of Capitol Hill everybody in
this city knows it and so is therefore
now that you're out of the White House
you go into war with absolutely the main
question I had after watching this
interview you can watch the whole thing
it's about an hour long is how Charlie
Rose got his job he just comes off so
poorly and uninformed and like a
left-wing hack but this is CBS News so
perhaps it was ever thus
to comment on the swamp I bring on now I
have the great privilege of bringing on
my friend a very long time the first
female physician ever elected to
Congress she represented New York's 19th
congressional district until we got
gerrymander doubt and a few extra cities
were added in my friend dr. nan Hayworth
nan thank you sir and I I was able to
win that election for the sake of all
the people we think so much about thanks
to you you were an incredibly potent
force for us and everybody who knows you
is not surprised to hear that so thank
you thank you nan and some day on the
show maybe I'll start telling some
stories about all the lawsuit lawsuit
threats and the ex rock star isn't that
came out of that campaign because it was
the most fun thing
in the history of politics you are too
humble man we must get into the politics
of what Bannon is talking about here he
is accusing DC of being an institutional
place he's saying the office of the
speaker is an institution office of the
leaf excuse me the office of the leader
is an institution there are forces like
lobbyists and think tanks and donors and
this and that and this then the other
thing that are controlling Washington DC
now you were elected on a tea party wave
you represented a very important
district you were on the Financial
Services Committee you were I believe a
deputy whip you helped it was one of the
pressing whips yeah one of the freshmen
whips is he right is are these guys the
swamp monsters and if not where is the
swamp how do we drain them well Michael
in some ways the swamp is in a sense the
swamp is ourselves except you from that
company but no you make a great point
it's if we are not the one of the many
lessons I learned when I was in Congress
was that we look to our electeds to
change things but they will not be able
to change anything unless they have the
support of their constituents and most
of these especially I'm the long-term
public servants quite honestly ourselves
those who should be Public Service
long-term electeds
are there because they have managed to
satisfy their constituents so if we want
really to change we have to look to
ourselves as Americans and say we have
to understand what we ask all these
people to do when we send them to
Washington we have to understand the
framers brilliant design for the federal
government the limitations of the
federal government and how far we have
exceeded them and unless we do that we
are not gonna get change for the better
and we're not gonna get changed that
makes the people who are seeking change
happy with what happens you're making an
obvious point that nobody in this
populist climate will make which is that
we are the swamp monster David Mayhew
became a famed political scientist for
making the incredible observation that
members of Congress are primarily
motivated by reelection and they will do
what their constituents tell them to do
what their constituents ask them to do
and then their constituents will
complain when they do it depending on
what happens that's right look if their
constituents understand perso when they
say we need to cut budgets and they then
understand that when you know when we
say that that means we're going to have
to cut some things that you like then we
could have a rational conversation about
these things but most of the time that's
not what's happening everybody wants
somebody else's ox to be gored it's
right exactly right and that's that's a
big part of the problem I have and
that's not to say by the way that I have
enormous sympathy for the predicament if
you will in which Senator McConnell in
particular finds himself I am
ashle quite angry that he doesn't move
to do the one thing that the president
has urged so strongly that I think has
to be done if we are actually to pass a
legislative package a legislative agenda
that achieves something approaching the
populous goals that the president
espoused and that is to put more
Americans back to work to make it
possible for employers and businesses
and small businesses to work better to
reduce the cost of labor in this country
and that means and the president's made
some progress with that as much they can
make from the executive branch in
reducing regulations and he has done
some things for which he deserves praise
but that's not gonna happen unless they
break the filibuster we're not gonna get
that package of reforms I totally agree
we have to break it I don't dislike the
idea of a filibuster but the way that
it's been abused by Democrats for so
long and the way that the government has
been abused by Democrats it seems to me
an unnatural step and it's surprising
that McConnell won't do it well they
like their prerogative and they worry
about being in the minority again and
that's what looms over their heads
no senator wants to give up a filibuster
but the problem is the Constitution
allows the Senate to create its own
rules
true but the filibuster is not
constitutionally required mandate I
don't remember that provision of the
Constitution right precisely
now it's also said and people will say
in praise of the filibuster or in
justification well you know the Senate
is supposed to be a great deliberative
body to which I respond absolutely and
guess what over the most of the 20th
century and into the 21st we have asked
the federal government to do vastly more
than its original portfolio so that we
were never meant by the framers to be
waiting on the Senate to reach consensus
about matters that have to do with how
citizens conduct their lives namely
pensions and benefits in particular
housing education since the 17th
amendment since the popular election of
senators it appears that the
deliberation of that body is the
deliberative nature of it has been
dramatically weakened well it's it's we
have and we've expanded that you know my
biggest concern is it was for many in
the last election was the composition of
the Supreme Court and Justice Scalia's
death was a blow I mean it was like a
punch to the gut
so that also of course emphasizes to all
of us what can happen when our side is
in the minority and we like to have that
filibuster power if you will - you know
forestall events that we would find
troubling like the elevation of a
Supreme Court justice whose opinion
particularly Commerce Clause was
different from Justice Scalia's would
have been the case had McConnell not
used the filibuster right - to block the
nomination but he had to break the
filibuster to elevate justice core
search and at this point this is this is
like football in two ways number one
Chuck Schumer's like Lucy he you know he
is the sanctimonious twaddle about how
of course now we have to compromise the
intones and oh you know there's no
intention right he's gonna keep moving
that football and Mitch McConnell's
Charlie Brown but the other way it's
like football is that we have to say at
this point you know what we've got to
play this quarter because we may not
have a game after this and if they don't
break the filibuster on cloture on
legislation they're never gonna reach a
package that will have enough fiscally
conservative reforms that we really do
need and I'm a partisan in that way damn
it we need Republicans to pass this
thing I don't want to exclude Democrats
but I don't want them to obstruct we're
never gonna get there unless they break
the filibuster legislation and to mix
metaphors as much as we possibly can you
bring up a point that I really admire
you for I really admire the way you've
conducted yourself from the last from
this last presidential election onward
which is that you have to play the hand
you're dealt
you have to play the cards in front of
you politics is not about imagining how
lovely it would be if something else had
happened or if we lived in a different
universe where Donald Trump were polite
and nice and behaved himself at cocktail
parties or that some that Jim Gilmore
were the nominee of the Republican Party
you have dealt Daniels I mean you and I
you turned me on to Mitch Daniels we
spent a long time trying to get that guy
to run but you know I've spent long
enough imagining what it would be like
to have that guy run for office and you
supported Donald Trump you perhaps the
most intelligent and educated member of
your class in Congress and possibly in
DC period you know I really admire this
because you come from circles that would
be considered educated elite intelligent
socially refined and you put your
political goals and the political good
of the country before your own image in
your own sense of associating with a man
who many consider uncouth well and in
know Michael we've talked about it but
President Trump
represented to me by far the better
alternative for all of us and he is
someone who has acknowledged the advice
and counsel of people like Larry Kudlow
and Steve Moore and art Laffer and David
Malpass all of whom have the best ideas
on how to move us forward in terms of
fiscal policy I know they're not the
only voices the president has heard but
but we know this quite firmly Hillary
Clinton would have given them no
credence and you know it if it's a
matter of aesthetics the president is
blunt
he's forthright and he sometimes says
things that others might with
justification find objectable for one
objectionable for one or another reason
but we don't elect a president based on
aesthetics we base it and look at how he
has performed with FEMA with all the
people who he and
administration put into place to manage
these two back-to-back enormous natural
disasters and he's got nothing but
praise for it when he's gone overseas
and he's talked with our allies they
have welcomed him this is a man who
understands far more than he's given
credit for and you know Michael I am I
have run out of patience with and you
and I both know the elites of which we
speak you're exactly right the the Ivy
League elites in particular and I'm on
the Princeton University politics
department Advisory Council I think I
was gonna present my diploma at I don't
know how I stand with them anymore but
it's nice that you've that you they
haven't totally kicked you out of the
Association wrapped of work that we did
and then it was kind of done for a while
but you know what I enjoy my appreciate
it and I think you know there's some
terrific people working there
including our chairman but at our
meeting in October before in 16 before
the election we had a discussion after
formal business was concluded about for
whom we would vote for president and I'm
not the only Republican on this
committee but I was certainly the only
one who said well I'm going to vote for
Donald Trump you were the only one you
were the only even among Republicans
Michael far and away I mean I was sales
well Michael is you know those whom we
brush if you will you know whom we give
the designation establishment
Republicans have at least as much
disdain or had at least as much disdain
for the prospective Trump voter as did
Democrats absolutely right that's
absolutely right and as certainly at
least as much disdain for Donald Trump
as they do for Hillary Clinton
oh absolutely well so many of them voted
for Hillary Clinton and I and I thought
you know number one I saw no moral
divide between these two candidates you
know I didn't think that that really was
a valid set of considerations at all for
a lot of different reasons you don't
think that Hillary is some example of
moral purity and virtue and
nobility and when she went with
Secretary Clinton was first lady and was
designated by her president than her
husband then President Putin to manage
health care I as a woman and as a
professional and as someone who's had
many blessings in this country and
understands that it's generations of
women before me who helped make that
happen but I was insulted because I
thought this is exactly the wrong
message to send that because you were
married to the president you know now
you are endowed with the power to
reshape the nation's healthcare who
elected you know one that's that's
absolutely right and so switching gears
just a little bit it is the the
anniversary of 9/11 you and I are both
New Yorkers I you know I was a kid when
it happened
what how should we think about our
nation our nation's response to that
terrorist attack our nation's response
to catastrophes in general 16 years
later well Michael it does as you know
these unimaginably horrible events do
lift the soul in showing us the best of
what our nation represents in the
response to not only in the immediate
time the incredible courage of the New
York police and fire departments you
know New York's bravest New York's
finest I mean nothing can compare to
what they did not only during the
attacks but in the aftermath but the
Wall Street Journal made a superb point
a couple of weeks ago and they had their
editorial board had an editorial I think
it was called disasters in the wealth of
nations and they were referring in the
immediate instance to hurricane Harvey
we will get through this and the reason
we'll get through this and the reason we
will read
is in no small part not only due to the
American spirit which we celebrate but
also due to the fact that we are blessed
to be within the worlds and history's
greatest economic engine of prosperity
ever known and that is not a random
occurrence it is not with us no exactly
it is by design the design of our
Constitution the most humane and
empowering document ever created and
unless we can fully appreciate when
calmer moments come and we can think
beyond the events at hand and beyond the
immediate need for recovery as we do now
for for Emma but as we did after
September 11th unless we think beyond
that to understand that we have to
empower those who are most productive
empower our workers not have a federal
government that imposes unreasonable
burdens to have elected officials who
can be modest enough to recognize that
it is not they who are the heroes it is
not they who are supposed to distribute
largesse to a needy public but it is in
fact their constituents who must be
empowered to have the dignity of working
and producing for themselves in their
society earning every founder Awards of
their work which exactly they don't
right now we have a federal government
that is confiscatory and predatory and
whatever they claim to deliver in terms
of benefits people like Charles Schumer
who want to set themselves up as our as
our heroes because they demand that the
federal government do everything for us
as much as you know that is actually
weakening us and taking away resources
and making us inefficient and
inefficient if ineffective and dependent
so we create wealth by putting Americans
to work and letting
do the rest that's a wonderful moral
case relating the int the spirit of
America the engines of growth that have
made America and our resilience are
almost our antifragility to borrow a
phrase from Nicholas Taleb in the face
of catastrophe in the face of natural
disaster and terrorist attacks there is
something about the American spirit and
the American system the American Way of
life that is under attack and it's under
attack by the left-wing in America
Michael as you know is actually it is
facilitated by prosperity and I think
that's one reason that President Reagan
said so cogently you know we cannot take
our great democracy for granted we must
fight for it with every generation
freedom isn't about one generation away
from extinction exactly exactly I mean
we see it happening on college campuses
you know your alma mater and mine and
they are not isolated alas you know have
actually instituted measures that
actively suppress speech that's right
they don't preach what they practice
they don't preach the mechanisms but in
their lifestyles or in their
professional lives that have allowed
them to become what they are absolutely
right man on that note we've taken up
way too much of your time it was so good
to have you here that what a what an
excellent message to leave on on this
anniversary and and but there's so much
more I want to talk to you about I want
to talk to you about Trump making deals
with Schumer and Pelosi I want to talk
to you about all those things but we
don't have time so we'll just have to
bring it back all right thank you nan
ladies and gentlemen and Haworth the
first female physician ever elected to
Congress with that we have got to bring
on our panel of deplorable z-- nan could
never be on the panel of deployables
because there's nothing too plural a
batterer other than the chief voted for
Donald Trump so right now we're very
lucky to have Jacob Airy and Emily
Butler so let's talk a little bit more
but let's go right back to the politics
we've had all of the up
lifting stuff from congresswoman nan
Hayworth so let's go back into Steve
Bannon perhaps not as uplifting I want
to know Emily does Bannon have any clout
or you know is is he speaking for the
Trump administration or is he just some
jilted ex-employee I don't think that
Bannon ever actually speaks for anyone
other than Bannon Bannon is out for
himself Bannon is a strategist at heart
he's speaking to an audience and maybe
that audience isn't exactly a parent
when you're watching him on you know CBS
or 60 minutes there is always a
hierarchy that's at play and with Bannon
especially at this point in his career
he has a new objective to think about
you know he reached his objective to get
into the White House that objective has
been fulfilled and subsequently tossed
aside so he has a new objective than he
needs to fulfill II as a new prerogative
and a new order that he needs to
establish so I would say there's a man
trying to regain relevancy is the first
step towards rebuilding his agenda much
less of an employee going rogue on that
note however I do think that as trump's
administration winds down or if there's
a new opportunity for Bannon to squeeze
in there he's probably not gonna hold
back on some negative comments from the
administration maybe not on Trump
personally hmm but there will definitely
be an opportunity that he will seize but
what's his idol here I mean why is he
going on 60 minutes why is he going into
the heart of stupidity and lazy leftism
with Charlie Rose I mean I'm not Steve
Bannon but if I was Steve band I'd be
thinking about what the plan is to get
back to the top of your empire he's been
totally wiped out he's been sort of
Dishonored a little bit ya sidelined by
being kicked out of the administration
so you have to think about what what I
need to do to rebuild and the first step
to that is getting as wide an audience
as possible while it's relevant while
people still want to hear from you both
the left and the right you see the same
thing with Hillary Clinton all at the
time just giving interview upon
interview on how she feels about her
loss you know
Bannen is capitalizing on exactly the
same thing he wants to speak out while
he's still relevant and while he's going
back to Breitbart and then if there's an
opportunity to catch any leftist
mainstream media in a hypocrisy in a
crosshairs he can seize on that he can
fight back on that with everything in
his jaws and come out looking even
better as he returns to restore himself
as the captain the leader the head of
Breitbart Charlie Rose is a hack but he
does have a network television platform
CBS is usually the first channel people
see when you turn on your TV yeah I
guess that's it just grab the platform
Jacob in that interview Bannen says that
the original sin of the administration
was making a deal with the establishment
Republicans that they're playing nice
with them is he right and isn't there a
fair question how would they govern
without establishment republicanism
well I think it depends on what he means
by establishment Republicans because
some people are lumping in conservatives
who I should say real conservatives in
with the establishment Republicans so I
don't know if that is who Bannon is
referring to but I think Trump is a deal
maker right that's what he always
bragged about I'll make the deals I'll
make the best deals and so for him to
say oh it's the original sin to deal
with the establishment Republicans the
GOP is the party in power who else is he
gonna make a deal with I know he's he's
chiming in about making a deal with
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi but if he wants
to move his fiscal policy forward and
everything that has to do with
immigration he has to deal with the
establishment Republicans because the
Democrats aren't going to help him so I
don't really think it's fair to call it
the original sin of the administration
fair enough there's the religious ruling
from Pastor Jacob Barry we now a pastor
former pastor Jay Perry we Nunn like
Paul Bois who's the future Pope we now
have got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube now I know you all want to keep
listening you want to talk to the panel
of deplorable you want to hear about
Pope Francis and illegal immigrants and
Miss America and a final thought about
9/11 but the only way that you can do
that is go to daily wire.com right now
it's $10 a month $100 a year you get me
you get the interplay and show you get
the Ben Shapiro show
forget all that bad what what is that
worth a nickel a dime but you get the
leftist here's tumblr this I would pay
at least the cost of a hundred Steve
Crowder mugs to get this leftist here's
tumblr it is the finest vessel for your
leftist ears known to man you can have
them hot or cold they'll always be salty
and delicious and it will never rust
from the salt of those leftist ears so
go over there right now Daly wired.com
and we'll be right back
[Music]
Pope Francis suggested today that
pro-lifers must support Obama's
executive amnesty saying the President
of the United States presents himself as
pro-life and if he is a good pro-lifer
he understands that family is the cradle
of life and its unity must be protected
he added I think this law comes not from
Parliament but from the executive if
that is so I am hopeful that it will be
rethought Emily you're a Catholic what
is a good conservative Catholic to do
with left-wing popes probably the same
thing that any good patriot needed to do
under President Obama which is just kind
of hold your tongue take the doctrine as
it comes and wait for a new pope popes
before this isn't a new thing sometimes
the Lord sends his bad popes to let us
know that the Pope is only infallible
when he's not fallible and I'm not even
saying he's a bad Pope but he does weigh
in a lot on matters of domestic American
politics which seem not to have very
much to do with Scripture so the number
one priority of the Catholic Church is
the salvation of souls in that doctrine
it does say that the Pope is
quote-unquote infallible that goes back
to Catholic doctrine well he's
infallible when he spits exactly right
he's infallible when he speaks ex
cathedra right on matters of doctrine
this does not have anything to do with
personal opinions on climate change it
doesn't have personal opinions on
immigration those things that he says
are sort of unique to this Pope himself
we're not necessarily as Catholics
obligated to heed or obey anything that
he says from his personal lectern when
it comes down to doctrine he's still
very Pope like you've seen him I mean
you see him come back to you know sort
of irritating the leftist with
reiterating his stances the Catholic
stances on abortion transgenderism these
are things that are still Catholic
doctrine he said of gay marriage - he
said
when it was up for a vote in Argentina
that this is not a mere political issue
but it is quote a machination of the
father of lies that seeks to deceive and
confuse the children of God does not
sound like a Democrat in that statement
no and I think I recall a long time ago
where he tried to personally sort of
make gay marriage or gay relationships
not a sin and kind of got slapped back
down by the church from that and then
came out and sort of backtracked that
statement that he made it's always
difficult because we have this lens of
the mainstream media so the Pope says
something and he might be making some
political point it might be a small
point and then the Huffington Post blows
it up like you know the Pope doesn't
believe in Jesus anymore and you say
well I don't I didn't see that anywhere
in his statement Jacob
whatever happened to render unto Caesar
that which is Caesars st. Paul writes
quote let everyone be subject to the
governing authorities for there is no
authority except that which God has
established the authorities that exist
have been established by God
consequently whoever rebels against the
authority is rebelling against God of
what God has instituted and those who do
so will bring judgment on themselves and
that would seem to be the case for the
immigration laws of the United States is
the Pope contradicting Catholic teaching
by denouncing the enforcement of a
perfectly legitimate law I don't
necessarily think so I fear hell you
don't want to be struck down on the spot
sure enough I don't think that I think
what Paul is saying that you you can
have a personal opinion and I honestly
think the Pope's on what the Pope's
words don't affect our policy so I think
it's OK for the Pope to have a personal
opinion I just want to know where his
opinions are on the encroaching
socialism and secularization of Europe
as opposed to this one law in the United
States and often people misquote the
render to Caesar what is Caesar's what
is the question that is asked of Christ
is is it a sin to pay taxes to Caesar
and so he says rendered a Caesar what is
Caesar's and to God what is to God he's
not he was saying it no it is not a sin
to pay your taxes because there were
there
certain shall we say pious groups back
then who were teaching that and saying
that's not thing is a sin to pay your
taxes never do it I try to avoid it as
much as possible Catholic Church the
Catholic Church is not the only
venerable institution that is speaking
less than infallibly about American
politics this has even infected the Miss
America pageant 2018 we don't have the
clip I thought we had the clip of it but
one of the questions that was asked of
Miss America was what do you think about
the Trump collusion narrative did Donald
Trump collude with Russia to win the
election and how so and when will he get
caught Jacob why does the Left have to
make every good thing boring they've
ruined colleges they have made sex
boring that now they're going after hot
chicks in bikinis why can't we have nice
things it's exactly what you said they
cannot leave it alone oh my gosh I you
know I just want to see I don't care
what she thinks about the Russia
collusion conspiracy theory because
that's all it is a conspiracy theory you
know I know Maxine Waters
she likes to talk about the Kremlin
kraut clan and she likes to go all over
the place and sing the Internet's trying
to kill her this is where these the left
is getting their information leave Miss
America alone you know Emily you bring
up a great point because this is a
conspiracy theory at this point Emily
does the left really believe that anyone
cares what Miss America thinks about
these crazy Democrat conspiracy theories
or is this just about coercing every
aspect of the culture to recite and toe
the line on leftist orthodoxy as like a
member United States and as like a
member of the human race I think it's
important that like all of humanity have
their voices heard so I think that of
course it's important to hear what we
say especially
as an American beauty pageant contestant
I'm really pretty you know that was more
intelligent and coherent than the
question that was asked of Miss America
so kudos to you on that I think if I can
answer seriously mom I think that
probably the people who care the most
about what the American Miss America
pageant contestants have to say is the
contestants themselves clearly you know
when you're talking about all these
questions that have been posed to them
the political nature of the questions
and you can hear how they want the
question to be answered so when you're
acquire a pageant contestant you're
standing up on the stage all you care
about is like winning this crown right
so you're going to reiterate back
anything that they're going to ask you
exactly how you think you want how do
you think they want the question
answered so when you look back at it
it's there's not really like anything
that they're saying that's real or that
like they actually care about her
they're believing in it's about
continuing on this narrative about
something they probably haven't even
researched absolutely right and I'm rude
by the way I'm really upset the only
reason that I wanted to talk about Miss
America today was to be able to watch
them on the screen during this and we
don't have the clip so it's absolutely
pointless as far as I'm concerned okay
panel of deplorable 'z Emily Butler and
Jacob Erie thank you for being here
we'll have you back now it is the it's
the 16th anniversary you know of
September 11th and so we haven't talked
about it very much and I'll I think I
would like to talk about that in my
final thought so I'll put on my smart
glasses
it's the 16th anniversary of the
September 11th terror attacks my 6th
grade math teacher broke the news to us
in suburban New York my mother saw the
Towers fall with her own eyes and from
Harlem she made it onto one of the last
trains out of the city some of my
classmates parents didn't make it out of
the city not that day and not ever after
the second plane struck father George
Rutley ran from midtown to the Twin
Towers to offer wartime absolution to
the firemen rushing into the buildings
the first confirmed death on that day
was a Catholic priest named Michael
judge next to the towers in st. Peter's
Church the first Catholic parish in New
York Father rattler met fireman who
carried father judges body and recalled
quote they put his body in front of the
altar it was very moving there's a
picture of the crucifixion over the
altar I remember blood coming down the
altar steps I shall always remember that
scene the image of oak's st. Paul's
letter to the Ephesians we wrestle not
against flesh and blood but against
principalities against powers against
the rulers of the darkness of this world
against spiritual wickedness in high
places sixteen years ago President
George Bush put it in his own words and
I'll leave you with that the pictures of
airplanes flying into buildings fires
burning huge huge structures collapsing
have filled us with disbelief terrible
sadness and a quiet unyielding anger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]